yeah
[Music]
for first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
this is hot once the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings today
I'm joined in the studio by gunplay aka
Don Logan the new album living legend
gunplay fans gonna be very excited for
this because it finally has a release
date right July 31st and pick it up July
31st do you know how the show works long
as we drinking every single bottle you
know I don't care how it works don't
think I'm gonna be out right yeah don't
worry we're not gonna Chuck these
bottles here we have 10 wings ten sauces
and ten questions okay we're gonna start
off with easy questions
easy wings because as you work your way
down the line they get hotter a lot
hotter so hot in fact that you might
need to tap out so if the wings are too
hot and you have to call it quits your
safe word Mehdi Ian you just say it and
you don't have to eat any more wings if
you make it all the way through without
incident if you don't need to tap out
you get thirty uninterrupted seconds at
the end to plug whatever you want if you
don't make it all the way through I take
half of your plug is that cool with you
or do you need the stakes to be a little
bit higher I'm cooler than a polar bear
toenail oh well but if you want to go
ahead on and throw $20 if I tap out you
get forty bucks if you tap out I'm
taking a cash gonna play all right but
you got to go to your car so I might get
that money back all right bro you ready
to do this yeah let's do it I come play
here your hot ones
just for you we went to Wingstop do I
thank you thank you yeah the Winstar
baby you know you know how we do we keep
it hot come on let's go all right ready
no big deal on the first wing right so
my first question is about Wingstop
mm-hmm when you and Rick Ross walk into
a nightclub on South Beach I imagine
that it has a certain vibe to it
and I like to think that when you and
Rick Ross walk into Wingstop that you
carry that same energy so let's say you
guys smoke out in the Maybach pull up to
wing stop what does that order look like
before you own the chain of wing stops
we used to eat we stuff all the time
and to see him actually own a chain of
them has more wings for me are you like
a fat boy I might look don't don't get
it twisted
are you like a frat boy looks like up
again I'm gonna get my own thirty
seconds of fame are you talking [ __ ]
after the first wing are you ready
number two so two loop so ruler yeah
Tallulah hot sauce Mexican yep
I don't know probably right okay oh yeah
it looks like yeah from Mexico yeah
we're going to make oh I'm not lip
where's I have to know have you finished
your bomb shelter yet no I haven't even
started and I'm so I'm so torn for the
party dammit there's gunplay have any
things that he would want in that bomb
shelter like would you have a rider for
that bomb weed porn and chicken wings
[Laughter]
alright number three is the L Yucatec Oh
Caribbean habanero you love fishing
right I'm in fishes in seven six years
old my dad always wanted to take me out
of the hood you know just so me
something different when I try to stay
out of trouble that's when I went back
fishing again have you ever been injured
fishing like have you ever been stuck by
a Marlin or anything like that [ __ ]
let's just dig me I'm gonna stick it
back Hey Joe how's that hi man you ready
for number four if you is so this is the
lottie's sort of this like mustard
colored one mustard on the wing
Oh what's the quickest way to get kicked
off of gun plays tour bus we're smoking
crack oh my [ __ ]
if I smell a rock burning yeah you in
trouble don't smoke crack on my boss I'm
the only one that's won't scratch on my
smoke
it seems like a fair deal for me all
right what we got now all right
see everybody always comments on that he
is in a lot of pain he's screaming are
you here or you win okay I'm up man you
gotta eat eat the groceries all right I
like getting on that's why you went
through full time sitting here you do
like this on the lower you go yeah so uh
next question
well you know not be the only through
the fifth wing jump lay there no that's
not a thing like Bobby I know this game
which Miami strip club is your favorite
the office why cuz I just want to go
where everybody knows
you know I'm coming near break my
records so you say break your records
you know like a lot of times comedians
will go to like a comedy club to try out
new material is it kind of the same
thing with your music like do you bring
music and you see how the club react I
don't care about the the crowd reaction
cuz you could if you listen to the radio
you can say fart fart poop or on a
record and it was that [ __ ] because it
got played a thousand times I want the
DJ's reaction he's the one playing the
music making the crowd just say I'm say
he's the plug cheers all right
halfway home man and you're feeling good
please so this one pain 100% hot sauce
which is like two and a half times
hotter than a jalapeno this is where the
game changes something tells me you're
not gonna be talking [ __ ] about cleaning
off the wing anymore that this is where
the game changes we am [ __ ] you did
this fo times how many elses you got
Shannon the Canon Briggs that's my
[ __ ] play up on door so when
he's going around like [ __ ] with
Klitschko and stuff is that all real
like is that is that really who that guy
is like is that dude he's got no champ
dude of course he's gonna oh he's over
here let's go and he's gonna sit there
and he go hey let's go champ
just type with Niki is man and you gotta
love it yeah yes let's go champ
let's go cheer let's go champ let's go
change let's go Tim you know what I mean
now we're off to death now we're off to
this is number seven which is Blair's
original Dutch gonna be a living legend
man you don't give me death wipes not
when you eat enough what the chicken
mine
no mr. yock bathroom yeah so you're a
pretty tatted-up guy what was your first
hat what was your last hat and which one
means the most to you this was my first
one I was uh sixteen this before I got
into my religion of Santeria and if you
see it say so for God loves the world
that gave his on it like out [ __ ] come
on what you doing so God's will of the
world that and he had to cross around
and He gave His only begotten Son and
and whoopee whoopee whoopee whoo what
was the last the last one oh right here
this fresh too
oh yeah those are friendly let me touch
it yeah I just got these in a lake and
then the one that means the most to me
has to be my heart I pee peanut on my
back because I was a real close friend
of mine sucks to even talk about it you
know I mean well thanks for sharing it
was that close thanks for sharing
alright ready for what do we at 8/7 was
alright right get out of here
get out of here nothing like this is
Dave's temporary insanity hot sauce
which is 12 times hotter than a jalapeno
and you're nice more jalapeno this one
right here is the rest of them I really
like this one's not kicking for you
nothing this outside look at the
GameChanger
that's just kind of like then they call
a asthma attack my heart rate blood
pressure raised up are you serious
you're not feeling this
that's a heart attack there right I'm
still the burn that I have is not from
these it's from this [ __ ] right
here good lord
if I finally met my match I've been here
the whole time
what's the lamest thing about the rap
music industry the lack of creativity
the lack of individualism got a great
lot of great rappers but can you relate
to what they talk about do they strike a
chord in your heart when you listen to
do you get the goosebumps when you
listen to him so if you have you know
money's in motivation and you gonna fall
for any of you stand for something or
fall for anything
what we got you wing number nine so this
is Dave's so we've gone from Dave's
temporary insanity hot sauce to just not
acknowledge man
Dave's insanity hot sauce it's no longer
so they say feel like we're going back
to [ __ ] this one well are you kidding
me by the way this is I'm telling you
that's what you don't need in your life
freak you've done in the past the
clothing line
the hush service what's the next
entrepreneurial venture for gunplay
putting out my player partner my dog my
artist pairing on Jay King
you know I'm he been through too much
he's hard-working he has a lot of songs
so that's my next venture is putting out
my [ __ ] play a part in the whole
rule P Jake hey Mike no Mike no Michael
loop alright on this tap it up okay yeah
like rich oh god I kind of bled a little
heavy
hey bro it's not this stop
quite uh that's kind of like the
best-tasting one for room you're insane
are you serious so thank you and uh mmm
have one more question though which was
the tougher habit to kick
cocaine or call of duty dude you play
like I'm line with like C it's a late
bloomer yeah yeah that's a late bloomer
right there right no milk
that ain't no [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
creeper but I quit cocaine cold turkey
2008 Memorial weekend I was just tired
of doing it people is telling me stop
stop stop I was [ __ ] I'll do it I'll
stop when I want to stop the way I quit
call of duty I'm just not too busy
that's it but so I play fight night I'm
about 2600 wins and 200 and maybe thirty
losses so you know and if anybody wanna
holla at me is jus Mike Tyson just my
tyson for anybody out there are you like
if somebody barks at you through the
headset i buy that do you fight back you
have to bark back on that gunplay has
great trash I'd be talking [ __ ] of
course the spring when it's one-on-one
you got a month in fight night what what
do you went well I met Bob in Miami what
was someone's idea but with meeting
right now you can ask my dog if I'm
lying my momma [ __ ] and I'm flying call
my dog he had to be the voice of reason
for five minutes
but you know I mean about to go to jail
over Xbox don't without a bit
well nothing but the best going forward
gunplay and if anybody has earned their
30-second plug it's certainly you you
can look right into the camera you can
look at me but whatever the floor is
yours for 30 seconds you've earned it
man let me tell you something I'm gonna
play Don Logan Jupiter Jack eight off
sniffler ratchet Morales
I got album coming out July 31st living
legend sundar Maybach music you know
what them to understand for money mayhem
machines and machetes Maseratis
[ __ ] making miracles money
motivated Miami material you made back
music Def Jam shout out to them it's all
about living legends July 31st PJ cake
black Bilderberg Group being a building
man is going down shout out to complex
and in all these wings you see my
victims but I don't
[Music]
you